♪ ♪
- That movie was so long.
- It was 62 minutes.
- Exactly. Nothing should be
longer than a "Gilmore Girl."
- Mm.
- Hi. Thank you.
Can you put these
under Billy Eichner?
- Wait, he's here?
- Oh.
I'm just assuming.
- Anyways, the movie
probably felt so long
because it was so problematic.
- Totally.
[stammers]
But, like, how would
you say it was?
- Well, I mean, it was
so racist to Italians.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
I love that we both hate racism.
- Yeah.
- So...
Tell me more about yourself.
Like, where do you live?
What kind of bed's in there?
- Well, I have a king-sized bed.
- Okay.
- And I live in Midtown East.
- Oh, no.
I'm not going there.
- What-what?
[muffled dance music thumping]
♪ ♪
- [sniffs]
[phone chimes]
Ha ha, great party.
[door opens]
Huh-huh, great party.
[deep voice]
Huh-huh, great party, dude.
- It is a great party.
Glad you're having fun, man.
- Oh, uh, no, no.
I'm, uh, I'm auditioning
for a commercial.
I'm an actor, uh.
I actually went to
the same theater school
as Patrick Wilson's cousin.
[urinal flushes]
But I'm in New York now,
mostly doing theater.
Or I--I want to
start doing more theater.
Um...
[women laughing]
[shoes squeaking]
- Oh, my God,
it's honestly so tragic.
- I know.
And in this climate?
all: Exactly!
- Hi, I'm Brooke.
I was gonna wear jeans to this
'cause I'm rich,
but I just thought
that was too obvious.
So that's why
I'm in this huge gown.
- Cool.
- Totally.
- Our friend Zita was just
talking about not having a job.
- Wait, what?
Oh, my God, that makes me
feel so much better.
I don't have a job either.
- Yeah, I'm kind of spinning out
about what I'm gonna do next.
- [exhales]
- Zita, relax.
You don't have to do anything.
- Mm-mm, mm-mm.
- Yeah, girl, this is
the beauty of retirement.
- [very soft laugh]
- You're retired?
- Yeah.
- Of course.
We all are.
- [soft laugh]
- You know how it goes.
Your teens are for working.
Your 20s are for resting.
- Well, what are your 30s for?
all:
Making a global impact.
- [soft laugh]
Oh, shit.
- Brooke.
Thank God.
- Here.
- Oh, this party is not fun.
- Yes, it is.
I'm having fun.
- You are?
- Mm-hmm.
Well, not like fun fun,
but, you know, party fun.
[soft laugh]
- What is--what?
- Party fun,
when everybody at a party
just agrees to
perform fun at each other
and it's the collective effort
that makes it fun!
You know, like, uh,
like this little model girl.
She's not having fun fun.
- [soft laugh]
Yes, I am.
- Okay--yeah, but you know,
when you're alone with
your thoughts in bed tonight,
you're not gonna look back
at this party and think,
"That was fun fun."
- [soft laugh]
Yes, I will.
I'm having the time of my life.
And I'll think back often to
just how much fun this all was.
- Okay, well, she's a model.
She doesn't know her own brain.
- I'm not a model.
I'm an EP on the film.
- Jesus.
- Okay, well,
your movie's racist.
[hip-hop music playing]
- Yeah, so now
I'm focusing on theater mostly.
- Cool, um...
- I think.
- Do you know where
all the celebrities are?
I thought Tinsley Mortimer
was here.
- Oh, uh, I think
she got turned away at the door.
- Oh, I could have sworn
I saw her.
I haven't seen
ChaseDreams yet either.
I wanted a picture.
- You did?
- Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, I mean, I haven't--
I haven't seen him in a while.
But if I do,
I'll send him your way.
What was your name?
- Brittlyn.
And thank you.
I love ChaseDreams.
He's like the cutest boy
in the whole world.
- Cutest boy?
- Everyone's saying
I should incorporate,
but I don't know
if it's worth it.
- I think it is,
'cause you could deduct
all your business expenses.
Think about every time you fly.
- I just feel so dumb
about this stuff.
Like, should I get
an LLC or an S Corp?
What do you have?
- Um, you know, actually--
I don't--I don't think--
I'd get either
in this climate.
- Hey, Streeter,
I can't find you guys.
Can you put Chase on?
- Chase can't talk right now.
His neck is bound.
- What?
- Yeah, I'm just trying to keep
his Adam's apple under control.
Gotta keep that neck
looking young and slick.
[chuckles]
- Ew, don't do that.
Where are you?
- Uh, we're on
a plane to Pittsburgh.
- What?
- Yeah.
He's got a concert at 9:00.
- How?
He has one song.
- Well, the grind never stops.
So what are you doing,
gay brother man?
Still tearing it up
at the, uh, AP?
The after-partay?
- [sighs]
I'm sure Brooke is.
She loves this kind of stuff.
She's probably having fun
around here somewhere.
[toilet flushes]
Well, um, this woman
named Brittlyn
wanted a photo with Chase,
but I guess whatever.
- Brittlyn?
Oh, my God.
That would have been
huge for Chase.
She's like the biggest
11-year-old on Instagram.
Her makeup tutorials
are like next-level.
- What?
Brittlyn is 11?
She looks like she's 30.
- Yeah, I said her makeup
tutorials are next-level.